[Music]
Hey
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
the lobby GameSpot's weekly video game
hangout here in San Francisco California
I'm your host as always Mike McCarty
here with Peter Brown
I'm always Peter Brown as well Rob
Hanley that's me Cali play it me what's
up we got one more week before we head
down to Los Angeles for Electronic
triple big ass game announcements yeah
much excitement yeah we we are putting
up
well for starters next week we are going
to be doing a lobby and we'll have all
of our UK crew and Australia crew in
town so we're going to try to like get
them on the lobby as much as possible
we're just going to do a pre e3 kind of
like what we all individually want show
we also have a lot of features going up
later this week or next week starting
Friday
all the way through the next Friday so
one whole week yeah we'll have like pre
press conference primers kind of like
what we know will be at the show for
Sony Microsoft Nintendo as well as EA
ESDA Ubisoft and then editorial team is
also working on a lot of write up for
that so for the next week of course as
we lead up to III we will have a ton of
coverage on that but we'll get into the
show as always we have a giveaway today
I don't have it here to show but it's a
razorblade 14 inch gaming laptop this is
actually a big deal yeah it's a really
nice laptop yeah do you know how much
he's run for a couple thousand dollars
yeah it's probably it's good to have a
1080 in it I'm assuming uh you know I
don't know some sort of razor is pretty
good about keeping their stuff up to
date and I really do like the form
factor these things cool I'd like to
have one yeah as always Shiva are who
runs our Twitter account she will be
tweeting the giveaway tweet from
GameSpot's account if you don't follow
us on twitter go do so and then retweet
that specific tweet we're doing it a
little differently this week rather than
later on this week announce the winner
we're gonna pick a random whirl we'll
announce it on next week's lobby or at
least around next week's Lobby so you
have a whole week to because it's such a
big giveaway you have a whole week to
try to get your retweet in and then
we'll pick a random winner and hopefully
it's you uh some news Peter Brown Friday
the 13th experiencing some server issues
is that still the case today this was
yesterday when I wrote these notes oof
we have a lot of issues of that game
yeah um so the PC version is currently
pretty stable I'm getting into a lot of
matches with high neo pings with their
club yeah though server issues their
status of the servers and you know
surveys aside this game has a lot of
bugs I've been in more than a few
matches or people have figured out a way
to fly and are currently glitching their
way from death which as Jason makes it
impossible to win okay and there's a lot
of other just minor issues and stuff
like that but on consoles this game is
essentially unplayable unless you're
getting into private matches quick
matches are at least as of last night I
haven't checked today but as of last
night quick matches were not possible on
PlayStation 4 or Xbox one the developers
are working as they put it around the
clock
and you know they're sort of beholden to
Sony and Microsoft's patching and
release system schedule which I think
Microsoft's is supposed to be today but
Sony was supposed to be yesterday and I
didn't see that pushed um so we'll have
to see kind of a bummer that this game
is essentially an early access game you
just wouldn't know it because they're
not calling it that like on any
storefront and it's 40 bucks um a lot of
fun playing it with you guys playing
with strangers kind of boring I mean
yeah for the most part yeah as long as
you have Mike that's key right I'm Mike
right here and thanks Oh to go back to
the price and quickly you said later on
there's gonna be a boxed version that's
a full $60 yeah physical versions gonna
be 60 bucks and when the devs are asked
why they said well we're passing the
savings along to our most passionate
fans who are going to download the game
I don't know what the hell they mean by
passing on the savings it doesn't really
make any sense frankly they're just
gonna be charging more for the physical
version that's that's the only way to
talk about this alright 50% markup
because of these issues we are holding
the full review you're you still have
your review and progress up yeah by the
end of the week I'll have my full review
because I at least want 200 at least
want to test Ibaka baby
this was good yeah rice nickel margarita
and that was only so Nick didn't see
that I was him playing but I think that
was Aaron spectating had that glitch
where he was still in a car position
yeah guess what the kids call it there's
a n there's this game has a lot
my favorite yeah that's like it's number
12 in a Kama Sutra yeah so we're you
know we're keeping the conversation
going around this game but you know when
a game like this is really multiplayer
focused we're trying to give it a week
after launch to get itself together but
yeah this doesn't work on ps4 Xbox one
the score is gonna have to reflect that
crashing off without everybody uh yeah
we have some pretty funny gameplay up on
a GameSpot we have some archived twitch
streams as well right that's like yes
these are all archived twitch streams I
believe if you've got a PC and you've
got seven friends to play with yeah I
would absolutely well actually I don't
know that's a lot of money to spend on
this game that's I would not return $80
worth of game you could never mind
just wait there's so off other
multiplayer games also they all look
like Sims mm-hmm yeah yeah there's a lot
of that it it's a shame I don't know
I've been like this past weekend I
watched a bunch of the Friday the 13th
movies they're good they're fun to watch
yeah like them we have a drop again
another video but it's it's really great
is a Cali no chaste II put together a
compilation of the executions or kills
with actual real-life murder real-life
murder from the movies and it's fun to
see like the chesty killed real people
that's right the video like that head
punch off we just punches this dude's
head in the movie rolls down at Jason
Takes Manhattan
I believe I'm not familiar with the
movies I think it's Jason Takes
Manhattan um also that's the second time
today someone's confused me with
chastity that's right I did it earlier
uh we give reviews in progress we will
get to Pete's Tekken 7 review progress
is up we will get that later I can't
seem to write a full review uh so
half-assed Pete will have some Tekken 7
stuff to cover later on in the show I
only have one butt cheek uh Square Enix
announced a new RPG lost sphere yeah
looks just like I am setsuna yeah it's
Tokyo RPG Factory the developer of I am
setsuna and it's announced for a switch
ps4 and PC yeah um can you walk me
through a with this horrible is it a pun
the name lost sphere it's like spear but
with an H yeah
a true minor is that just translation
problems no not translation problems I
hate it it's it's a jack
it's a Japanese name yeah using English
I mean that you know they don't
necessarily have the best grasp of the
language 258 over 2 setsuna yeah right
no I mean I can't recall the story at
hand but honestly like I'm stats know
was a good game that was just maybe a
little bit too derivative for its own
good so I hope that this sort of strikes
its own you know establishes its own
themes and tries to not just be like
Chrono Trigger and you know with a
slightly new story inspired by other
games I'm excited for this Chrono
Trigger
I am set to knows kind of derivative of
Chrono Trigger so the music the combat
not necessarily the story but like
everything else other than the story it
shares a lot with creditors yeah okay
interesting I'd never played I am
setsuna but Chrono Trigger is one of my
favorite games as uh you can actually so
I'm system is available on switch I have
to play Final Fantasy Tactics first yeah
jerk you tell me every week what's the
best platform to fight on I'm not
telling you again
um and then in other news titanfall twos
monarchs rain update is now live as of
yesterday on PC ps4 I'm assuming Xbox
one is up the big three yeah Rob that
was our game of the Year last year
titanfall 2 and you and I have been
right
the was streamed it every time there's
new DLC except for this week we're not
doing to meet streams as we prep for e3
yeah we have a lot of work to do this
week so we had to hold all of our live
streams which is a bummer because I
think was a significant update yeah yeah
it's one of the best ones again free
yeah so let's get into it um it first
time it's a new Titan so there's the
original six and titanfall 2 if you're
not familiar and monarch is the new one
right here it's a vanguard Titan a
little more a little closer to BT who
you use during the campaign so broad
strokes what's this Titans deal what's
its kind of MO it's a really fascinating
and I think
I'm glad they did something like this
supposed to just you know I'm one of
what one of what you would imagine be
now that more basic Titans with like
just a little bit of customization there
is a lot going on this time and you can
really diversify your play style you
know there's been a lot of comparisons
to the title to compare the first one of
having a lot of MOBA / fighting game
influenced with the students and here
it's like in full swing where you can
customize this monarch Titan to be a
very support heavy have a very support
heavy role for like you know a the new
mode Titan brawl or like last Titan
standing right where you can one of the
abilities mark has is it can it's called
energy siphon so it's basically one of
its core abilities where you can shoot
another Titan and pull on its shield
incorporating into your own shield and
then one of the buildings you can
customize is you can get it back to
another Titan on your team then it's
it's crazy but but the main thing and as
with every Titan is you have your core
ability that you are see there in the
bottom left that you are ticking up to
then use but this one is so unique where
you have three customizable stages and
this is where the tide and get
fascinating and I find it so much fun to
play because you're constantly learning
and and developing and customizing
different aspects to like cater to like
one type of move where when I hit my
upgrade core right there you see in the
bottom now I have for instance one of
three abilities the in the first one is
a beefed up main weapon or there's so
many different ones or something that is
my one of the other abilities will allow
me to recharge my weapons quicker so I
can do that essentially when you drop as
monarch you want to hold back and get to
your stage three core ability and then
you are running cups like supreme around
the map and what were you going to say
just say that whatever havoc but it's
very much it's very much to slow burn
set its name
class right it's kind of like a hero you
don't want to you don't want to let this
hero get a lot of creeps on the map so
then they upgrade but yeah this is the
kind of manifestation of the MOBA
influences because like you said when
you land a you want it's a more of a
survivor class until later on if you
upgrade all the way but the conversely
everybody sees a vanguard or sorry a
monarch they're gonna say it we should
take that out before it upgrades all the
way right right that's kind of a target
for sure yeah um
currently everyone is a monarch it was
like when sambar on a release no sure
PTR stuff is so I'm excited and you know
people are back and forth with whether
its overpowered or underpowered I still
think it's pretty balanced but obviously
you know this game is always listening
to its community and it's always
balancing down the road so I'm excited
to see when yeah things kind of simmer
down and there's more
you know 1v1 moments in a time where
you're up against a North Star or you're
up against a legion and you're again
playing very differently depending on
that said tighten a little GameSpot
Easter Egg if you've been a fan of a
game spot for a long time Mary Kish uh
hurt they actually put her up
PlayStation tag on the gun if what time
no it hurt you can reach it's a reach
I'm joking but everybody who's watched
our streams has that ever saw Mary
kitchen screen tag it's like nineteen
numbers that she made it when she was
like eighteen and it still exists today
and it's a joke because on the gun it
says
got the first two numbers of her mk12
whatever
uh anyway yeah I didn't but I'm just
really excited with this game once again
and this is the new map relic but uh
from the first game and it's just so
revamped and this is I think now one of
the best Maps the multiplayer has to
offer with just such a versatile
landscape with like corridors and tons
of lanes and open areas like you it's
great they like they even have now
specters with like sniper rifle sniper
rifles the enemy AI oh [ __ ] yeah there's
this a bunch of new stuff actors or
Reapers specters okay spectres are the
robots and then Reapers are the biggest
of them just killing specters and
Reapers the AI contribute to your
upgrading your core so yeah one of the
abilities I had on here the
second core ability that your energy
siphon I was talking about it it gives
it like an insane amount of AoE so you
can get energy from a group of specters
because you know these guys comes in
waves right so you just point that
aground and get like three or four of
them combined because one isn't going to
do enough you want to use for most part
the energy siphon on of the bigger
Titans because you get more of your
shield back so it's a lot of shield
management the idea being that you are
consistently trying to keep your shield
on so the other the other really cool
thing you can do and everyone's doing it
now which is funnies there's another
ability where I can when you're doomed
and whenever Titans in doom state you
can engage a execution and I'm sure
everyone's seen it the trailer but I can
I get out when I engage it I get out I
punch you from getting out your Titan I
get on the back of your tie and I pull a
battery all the while my Titan is
slapping the guy again into his Titan
and then just destroying them once I get
back onto mine and put the battery and
it's uh and that there you go then you
have another battery automatically into
your monarch which will then allow you
to say if we are here crush the
depression at the best camera what
happens if you if it attacks a Titan
that's you know when you drop for those
who don't play it you can have your
tight and go into autopilot and just
fight for you if you want to stay on
your on your feet but if your Titan goes
to assassinate an auto and auto Titan
that's pretty really it's really funny I
saw this day on the bus was come in I'd
like totally had like a laugh-out-loud
moment you you punch into the autopilot
Titan the autopilot I'd and pull out
nothing because there's no pilot so it's
like the BT look where he looks his hand
and he like [ __ ] his head like yeah dog
and then he's like oh and then just
fishes off the guy then he kicks the
Titan yeah it's really interesting I'm
super excited also a smart move by a
respawn to include the new Titan brawl
mode yeah is this update because the
first time they've released a new Titan
so this mode is good if you want to
start learning I mean it's good for
learning any tight and honestly it's as
opposed to last time stations in it
where it's yeah it's an it's a would you
call like an execution bates based round
around me if you're out yeah execution
yeah yeah so then you have to wait to
the next round here you're just
consistently dressed it's basically team
death
match but you're only allowed to be in
your Titan yeah it's a great way to get
familiar with monarch and I would also
recommend if you again know this game
you can sway your kit loadouts to have
an increase of you start with 30% core
and then you there's another one that's
unique to this one where you can mark
where you can expedite the ticker-type
by tempor spent 10% so you can get to
those core abilities quicker do you see
yourself playing monarch a lot more are
you kind of just leveling it right now
yeah I oh yeah as you know me I'm all
about North Star I can't get away from
that Titan but here yet that this thing
is you there's so much you can do with
this Titan in so many different modes I
think it's perfect I think it's
something I'm consistently experimenting
with and you know just trying to get
better at it I I just love this game so
much god damn it Kelly titanfall 2
released before he joined GameSpot but I
know you're super into shooters are you
a fan of titanfall 2 or have you played
much yeah I didn't I haven't played too
much um I got it for my dad for
Christmas and you really liked it um so
I got to play when I was still visiting
my parents so I did like I had to stop
playing when I left but it's just like I
like I always focus on how the shooting
feels in an FPS and so I really liked
that aspect of titanfall too so I think
this is the kind of thing that I would
want to jump in cuz it sounds really
really interesting and I like being able
to experiment like kind of customize
your kit and like see what your role is
um thankfully there are no good games to
play right now right now yeah I have so
much time I have so much time to play
games right now so yeah I sit next to
Rob in the office and I was watching him
play yesterday and just watching you
jump around with the Mastiff shotgun and
then getting into monarch just it's the
last thing I need is a new Titan to try
out yeah yeah I joking obviously but
yeah it's funny to explain this cuz I
like still don't know this Titan that
well there is just so many different
factors that can attribute to like yeah
play style and you just trying to find
your own little niche there it's fun
yeah we will have gameplay going up
we're gonna try to get more up to night
I believe yeah check that out but I mean
if you if you have title 2 on any
platform you can go download this update
right now it's live yeah and there's oh
and there's also
this is the one component of like
timeful where you would pay for is like
cosmetics right so there's Ronan Prime
and tone probably the speaking versions
uh you have to either be level twenty in
the game in your current generation or
pay two hundred credits to unlock
monarch you kind of get screwed over if
you recently regen and you're at level
like ten maybe and you get a lot of
credits like Aaron yeah pretty bummed we
like that the update dropped and I'm
like oh and he's like I don't have yet
but for those who don't know regen
regenerating is essentially like
prestiging if you're at all duty player
um but yeah Aaron did that like last
week he said he's been holding off for
months before we knew this was gonna
come out like we didn't know we the
trailer went up yesterday that's suck
you showed me the trailer and then
Aaron's like oh it's live on PC and
there just threw off everyone but yeah
you kind of get screwed over but I don't
think it'll take that long
it does not take down Oh No cool uh I'm
looking forward to playing that uh we
also got to play arms recently the test
punch yeah um we you're reviewing the
game but we can't talk about impressions
from that at all this is strictly from
that very long demo period from last
Friday yeah last weekend yeah very very
like preliminary impressions so the
amount of Fighters we could choose from
was limited and I don't know this game
well enough to even remember which
fighters I remember the DNA dude helix
helix helix helix but I call it DNA man
yeah yeah that was the the Kendrick meme
that came out right after they show the
trailer his name right here uh we got to
play a little bit I know Nick margarita
played a lot of this demo Joey played
some of the Rob you and Callie both got
the chance to check it out yeah uh what
is this game because I look at it and I
think fighting games sometimes but then
obviously it's it's a lot more nuanced
than that and they're not more into us
on a fighting game but it's got its own
quirks to does its own spin it's like I
saw somebody compare it to like splatoon
as far as like it being technically a
shooter but being very unique spin on
the genre I know first party take on the
job yes
kind of how I see are amazing um but
basically the main unique thing is the
controls um it's I think it takes a
little while to get used to and so I
think uh the demo style is not really
enough to get a good feel for the game
because it you kind of have to retrain
your brain a little bit when it comes to
the actual fighting because as you can
see your arms are super long and that
changes the rhythm a lot and so a big
adjustment that I had to do when I first
started playing was being like how do I
time this properly to to really get a
good hit on the opponent more so than I
would in any other fighting game I've
ever played
sounds like side to side movement
strafing jumping dashing that was the
most the movement as far as yeah left to
right I found the most difficult yeah
what you were saying it you have to be
very much like reserved without with
everything because I can't like doing
the grab cuz my you know you want to
throw both punches but that that
actually just ends up being at grab and
then you're vulnerable so yeah you want
to like just kind of collectively think
about your your swings with the motion
controls right like um you have to
balance out like am I going to protect
here because your arm takes so long to
retract that your you're gonna be
without a guard for a little while um
and there is sort of this like
rock-paper-scissors style where a grab
will beat a block a block will be to
punch in a punch will be to grab and so
there there is that element there but I
think the main thing is like the
controls are so weird
not in a bad way but it just took me so
long to really adjust to like how am I
supposed to and the other thing is
movement is mapped to the same to the
left analog stick which is also what you
use to curve a punch so like I didn't
want a curve a punch but I need to move
to dodge a punch and so that threw me
off a little bit well because you're on
with the controller which yeah this is
playing if you're not playing with
motion controls with motion controls
it's interesting because movement is a
it's actually better you're doing tilt
you can you can tilt but you will have I
think a little bit more freedom to to
move while punching in motion controls
does it feel like this game was the
design from the ground up for the motion
controls like showcase the switch
absolutely I mean uh and I I'm a big fan
of the joy cons and like the the tech
that's in those like tiny little
controller adjustable yeah I loved joy
cons but um
yes soda jesting to that like oh I
haven't really used motion controls a
ton with mice which I think that it's
actually better with motion motion
controls but I was it was harder for me
also to throw those punches properly
especially when like your real arm is
not super long and so you're like oh if
I'm punching speak for yourself it's a
Peter Brown joke ruin it uh it also was
hard for me because I did martial arts
for a really long time so I'm like I
have an idea of like how I'd want to
throw a punch and it's just not at all
what I'm supposed to be doing and so
that was hard for me to just to that's
like it kind of martial arts did you I
did Kempo karate okay um well yeah I was
gonna say like in most martial arts
reach is super important right right but
your stance is not like the stance so
how realistic is arms but it feel it
feels good from we played right yeah no
I
I think after you get over that learning
curve um it it starts to feel really
good I love her she's the ramen girl so
isn't that robot character the only
actual human character or something is
that the more I think that was in like
the series well they had that big direct
kind of stream right imagine him coming
into like an MMA fight like like what's
his name uh McGregor is just in the ring
wave form and then you see DNA man
scampering up to like I'm like he like
wobbles he's so cute not fighting this
guy yeah so yeah I think right now
initial thoughts would be the once you
have to get over the controls I think
that initial getting over that that hump
can be difficult um but be patient would
be my advice for that arms and the title
makes sense to me but I wish if this
turns out to be a really fun game I hope
that just that generic name doesn't hurt
it because for me I didn't I
heard that and I saw it during the
switch presentation like I thought I
could have tried a little harder I
thought it looked so stupid when I first
saw it
like I its you have to get your hands on
it which is I mean I feel like that's
sort of been a Nintendo thing for a
little while
um where sometimes it's hard to get that
proof of concept like what was that the
Wii U in terms of naming so well I mean
even like trying Wii Sports versus just
if someone described Wii Sports to you
so um with arms when I saw it I was like
that looks really dumb and I have no
desire to play it and then actually
getting my hands on it there was more to
it so I think I'll have gameplay going
up over the next couple days I'm not
mistaken yeah we have some stuff up
already which you saw and I think
tomorrow there should be more tomorrow
then review embargo can you talk about
that I don't know if we can talk I don't
know that's sweet then we won't
ah cool so that's arms you can go check
out like I said gameplay that I'll be up
throughout the week if you want to go to
GameSpot comm or go to our YouTube
channel and watch that for more on this
weird take on the fighting game for the
Nintendo switch speaking of fighting
games Tekken 7 is coming out is it
Tuesday comes out this Friday Mike
Friday
that's a weird day for a game to come
out there but like that's happening
increasingly more often isn't it yeah
with a lot of questions phrase I'm sorry
I sometimes I talk and don't know where
my sentence is going and then I just
hope it ends up at a place during my
life
haha ever Michael Scott quo and I
butchered it but what were you just
allowed to say yeah I mean most games
come out Tuesday right but if it's not
Tuesday feel like Friday
it was Sunday you know it does Sunday
yeah
but pray was Friday there was like three
games were fronted wasn't horizon or am
I mistaken no I don't think horizon is
Friday Oh interesting
I could have sworn there was a few look
into this we'll get back to you yeah
well I investigate which is the whole
segment on Days games I'll be great I'll
fry a 13th Friday 15th makes sense yeah
uh but Tekken 7 Tekken 7 you're
reviewing progress is up on GameSpot you
want to read more depth but your
impression so far my person so far is
that
Tekin isn't never been a series that
changes all that much and that's very
true with this one but that's not
necessarily a bad thing
there's not that many 3d fighting games
on the market like yeah a lot of games
use 3d graphics but they're fought on a
2d plane
so among the sort of like peers that it
does have Tekken just feels like
something totally different and it's
fighting system has you know kind of
been refined over the last 22 years and
it kind of feels like it always has but
again that's not really bad because it
really is a great fighting game so you
know it's moved to Unreal Engine 4 this
is the first time it's on modern
consoles and NPC specifically PC and it
looks great the fighting is good they
have a few new mechanics the probably
the most important of those is this
thing called the oh crap I forgot the
name there it says move basically where
it's a move it has a property where you
have armor so if I initiate a punch but
you hit me while I'm going to punch you
I won't stop like I would have in the
past my punch will continue okay so it's
sort of like a you know risk reward
scenario where you know you're going to
take a hit but you're gonna actually
give a hit as well someone's like a
centimeter left of health you could just
get two quick hits and to finish them
well right as long as you have the
health to absorb there yes yeah like
rocket for yes but you know the other
part of checking outside of the fighting
is the ridiculous characters and story
this game kind of continues that
tradition of you know telling hello
that is weird weird as as not us yeah so
yeah it's a weird story about a family
of martial artists who are constantly
trying to kill each other are constantly
coming back to life as demons and
there's always like different
corporations involved it doesn't it
doesn't really make sense it's very
difficult to follow but that's kind of
it's made that way there's a lot of
comedic stuff as well a lot of secondary
characters are not really a part of the
main story they're treated as jokes so
you get this really nice mix of like
self-serious but kind of kidding stuff
and then outright comedy paired with a
fighting game that's very technical but
pretty accessible
do you like the characters in terms of
uh like their actual moves that's
fighting there yes like a good variety
yeah so the last game I want to say
there were 44 characters that has been
whittled down a little bit I think
there's somewhere like 32 now okay but
that means there's less copies you don't
have as many characters that seem like
you know just another version of another
character it's good but you know they
they all kind of fight so close together
that it's not really until you play
these characters that you really begin
to feel their their differences I will
say Akuma is now here from Street
Fighter and he plays very naturally if
you've plays true fighter before you
know how to play Akuma you can pretty
much jump right in and pull off the
moves that you want to but of course you
have to compete with them a little bit
differently as well it's not the same as
playing in a street fighter game in
terms of competition right so Tekken its
control conceit is that it you know each
button is mapped to a limb correct
record since Tekken 1 yes which is why I
consider this can be pretty accessible
because you know unlike a game like
Street Fighter where you're not really
sure like I mean you know what punches
and kicks are but here you you really
have this direct relationship between
this is my left arm this is my right arm
and that can help the thing is that this
game has so much death and it does
absolutely nothing to really guide you
characters have moved lists that are
upwards of like a hundred moves and
combos that are not broken down by
category in any way you literally have
to just scroll through them which you
can do by looking at the list or going
into training mode and like cycling
through one move after another it's a
long process you know like any fighting
game to become really good in this one
but it's flashy enough and it's
accessible enough that most people can
jump right in as long as their
competition is on the same level as them
have a good time you mentioned it it's
accessible in terms of controls and
everything looking back at injustice to
another recent fighting game that you
reviewed yourself as well and gave a
nine out of ten would you say that this
game is using that accessibility to kind
of like you said it's it is introducing
maybe new people to this universe but
also kind of not without sacrificing the
depth of the Tekken well I think the
accessibility here is almost
consequential
I think injustice to you know other
realms games in general like they try to
be accessible upfront I think just you
know what Tekken is is just inherently
accessible
I don't think they're going out of their
way because again there's no real
training right it's I mean just the
literal controls are easy to wrap your
head around sure not the actual movesets
of the characters okay as you get
farther into this review I was like I
was online going right now have you
tried much yet I've only had a few
matches with people in Europe and it's
been spotty connections so I can't say
which is why I'm kind of holding off on
the review this game will live and die
by its online component ok um checking
her Tekken Tag Tournament 2 was the last
yeah in the franchise that was 2000 I
want to say 14 14 and then Tekken 6 was
when 2008 Randolph reigns you reviewed
that one [ __ ]
he's our editor-in-chief now hey you see
so that was such like anger did he give
it a score he's a review many games
um um gave it a 8.5 okay the Tekken
Tekken games always score very well
because you know they're always great
and they don't need to change a lot and
they never really do what did we give
pokken poking got a 9 oh yes and that
was from tomorrow Z so uh in your early
hours or I guess you're pretty far in
now but in your time you spent playing
now it was worth the wait since the last
Tekken games yeah honestly I guy you saw
me on the lobby you know the weeks
leading up to this I kept like randomly
saying like also Tekken sevens coming
out like this series is very nostalgic
for me like it is you know when I think
about what it was like to own a
Playstation when those first came out
Tekken and a Ridge Racer like these
Namco Games like really defined what it
was to be a PlayStation owner so it's a
very special thing for me and I just
love the way that this fighting system
works the characters are just so batshit
ridiculous too it just it makes it fun
and there's a lot of collectible items
that you can get to customize your
characters so you can make a serious
jerk like Brian look like you know it
give him butterfly wings and pink pant I
mean you can just you can go all out you
can have a lot of fun screwing around
these characters there are no stats like
there aren't injustice that's just
aesthetics right right yes some of the
items you equip like in Tekken Tag 2 and
I'm not sure about Tekken 6 but some of
the items you equip can be used as
weapons so like I have a guy with a
pizza on his back that he can throw
across the ring and nice
Pete's pockets yeah like I told you this
games ridiculous why didn't you believe
me
props gonna go downloads right now I
love uh but yeah I mean those things you
know you're risky you're putting
yourself at risk to use them because
there's a very long wind-up but you know
they can change a character who doesn't
have a projectile oh yeah have you ever
heard I'll thrown a pizza in real life
dude that's not something you just sling
off the wrist you gotta get ready for it
depends on the crust you think yes
whether it's yeah New York or Chicago
dude if you throw a deep-dish pizza
someone they're not getting back up for
a while you guys watch did you get the
chance to watch the stream we did of
this last week that was the the weird
double lobby set for anybody wondering
we had what mr. knab's was that Richards
leaf for Richard Lee's first time on
camera for GameSpot so Richard Lee is
one of our more prolific fighting game
players here in the office but he's also
always behind a camera like maybe 80% of
the time if there's a video with like
camerawork it's Richard Lee but it was
fun to see him on a stream but like I
said he's also a big fighting game
player and we had i'm so sorry the name
of the player escapes mr. naps
mr. naps thank you very much you just
said that um the stream was pretty funny
because at one point he was using one
hand to fight like Ben and ten people
right at the beginning of the year oh
yeah so he was playing with one hand but
also he's playing with his left hand so
movement and buttons like he had to like
completely take his hand off of the
joystick yeah he was on the right side
right yeah I was so cool to watch and uh
like chassis is a huge Tekken fan and
she would always when we both were to
die GN together she would always like
sweep a tournament so just really funny
to watch them like be like how is he
beating us with one hand so definitely
check that out
yeah it's archived you can go watch that
on our YouTube and twitch channel or
sorry uh yeah YouTube and twitch and
GameSpot um do you have any D either you
have interests in Tekken 7 uh not quite
when you said pizza yeah you had me at
pizza um I want to try it out for sure
you see yeah it's like something I feel
like people should at least play the
brief little character stories just to
to get a sense of it because it looks
like such a self-serious game you
wouldn't believe how funny it can be if
you just dig into it it's actually not
that hard to find that stuff one of the
other cool things
has every cutscene from every Tekken
game ever made in it
what yeah which is pretty rad in their
original graphics or like yeah I did
know there was a solution so and
actually in the story mode it'll put
like if a character is thinking back to
a time it'll cut to like a lot just like
incredible
it doesn't take itself too seriously
despite appearances yeah I think Tech is
wonderful it's it's one of those games
that kind of gets lost behind the noise
of something like injustice and Street
Fighter um but I'm glad to see that it's
still kickin I know I've already kind of
recommended a few videos and articles on
GameSpot but I think it's last year -
more Huseyin in the UK interviewed
Harada oh yeah that's probably worth
checking out it being brought as a
character more as a character together
yeah uh those who don't know who Hirata
is cut Harada is sort of the lead of the
Tekken series and yeah he's a he's an
interesting guy always a sunglasses
always house always has someone always
has an opinion yeah he was at a last
year's pokemon world champion should
know I think was in Boston he was in the
which was two years ago um just like I
saw him from a distance of the
sunglasses on he's like surrounded by
women and it was awesome yeah look there
he is it's alright that's how you know
it's Hirata yeah man the women in the
sunglass the pantheon of doors yeah he
was there for pokken I should have yeah
so yeah so yeah team Tekken helped
develop pokken yeah yeah um to review
you have a tentative time frame next
week sometime I mean yeah we got to get
the service to go live and it's not just
about one view one matches there are
these like small tournaments they've
cooked up there's a lot of things need
to test so in a perfect world I'll have
a review ready Saturday I have a feeling
it's going to be in a day Monday so I
can play this weekend cool
I definitely check that out yeah they're
gonna have a renewed interest in
fighting games recently yeah uh yeah but
for those joining it seems like a lot of
people were waiting for a far cry 5 talk
now that the trailer came out those
character vignettes we know more about
it Kali you and Miguel concepción what
to see it behind closed doors were like
two weeks ago at this point yes um lots
to talk about I mean the cover art even
we talk we talk touch on the cover last
on last week's episode they released a
zoomed out version that's like the
entire table if I am not mistaken maybe
I dreamed that pretty sure I saw them
that that's all you're been thinking a
lot about far cry 5 yeah that's writing
about it because the zoomed I won't have
the guy with the sinner on his back
right that's in the that's in the one or
two they've definitely shown the zoom
that one yeah it has just like the full
table and if you know anything about the
painting and the Last Supper it's like
whoo I wonder wow the guy in Judas's
positions gonna be a character to watch
so I was looking at that a lot yeah we
talked about that already but now we
have the trailer in those character
vignettes we have a little bit more
sense of the flavor the game and you
actually put up a really good op-ed
there yes sir two days ago
Sunday Friday Saturday this Memorial Day
Memorial they throw me off so I went up
on Saturday okay and you were talking
about how the setting the story that
they have been talking about could
either be like a boon for the game or
could be a huge hindrance right and so
one of the biggest comments I've been
getting is people say you know don't
expect too much from a far cry game it's
not going to really be that hardening
and my response to that is they chose
the setting they chose the themes and
you're either going to do it well or
you're going to make something really
tone-deaf and I think that for it to do
well it has to really fully embrace what
it's going for and so I wrote about kind
of like the history of you know
separatist groups in the US and how the
government and law enforcement have
responded to them responded to them
often with force and so just kind of
because there's not parallel with far
cry 5 it's about you're a junior deputy
deputy going into this fictional County
of Hope County in Montana and kind of
using force to subdue this radical cult
and if it doesn't if the game doesn't
address those thing I mean this is this
is if you know if you were around I was
not I wasn't alive but the Waco Siege in
Texas where over 80 people ended up
dying there's just a lot of history
there that would be a mistake a misstep
to ignore I think and I don't think it's
out of bounds to expect a game that
shows the setting and shows these things
to to do a good job with them I don't
think it
no I'm not no one's making it political
it made itself political yeah and for
more context Ubisoft itself was
referencing that take over an Oregon
that well right refuge so that's why
that's basically why I wrote the piece
is because they mentioned the Eifert I
don't know how to pronounce it start
with an M but it has like weird vowels
the Wildlife Refuge in in Oregon which
was in 2016 so very recent only one
person died I think but basically if you
if you heard about it you probably know
that they people sent them some
phallic-shaped food and gifts and Nevada
Lube
and that's what it was like gay internet
but yeah so it's it they cited
specifically these anti federal
government groups these these groups
that have a distrust of government and
so that's that's kind of inspired me to
write the piece because it's like yeah
there are religious cults they're very
very extremist but they are also part
they're the you soft was inspired by
these more moderate groups how are you
going to address those those themes
yeah you've kind of already started
answer but John Luke I prepped I gave a
few Twitter questions to him before I
mark em uh he's a frequent sir ask
questions on the lobby but he was kind
of asking do you think that the
controversy behind far cry 5 will help
or hinder it from obtaining mass
critical or commercial success I think
the game will be commercially successful
regardless but and then critically I
mean it's up to the person who's playing
it whether it succeeds in doing that I
guess that kind of leads into what you
were just saying right like this could
be a huge advantage for it if it's seems
depression right yeah regarding recent
events but it also you know could be
maybe a little too timely if they [ __ ]
it up right that's what I'm yeah that's
what I mean by tone-deaf tone-deaf like
if you don't do it right it's going to
be really really cringey at best
so um critically it's up to the person
who's interpreting the game right
commercially I I think that it'll
probably still do well and I think I
don't really think of it as a
controversy either like um I know there
was like a change.org petition like but
it looked like I pretty sure that was a
joke um but I don't see it
super hindering the game yeah I mean it
seems very much like a direct response
to
Far Cry 3 & 4 you were very in 3 you are
actually like this former frat boy who
got dropped into this kind of I don't
know tropical wilderness I got with and
then what really went into the tribal
aspect to that and I don't know if I cry
5 seems to be maybe a direct response to
that yeah I do want to credit Ubisoft
for not doing like yet another
quote-unquote exotic location um because
I think there's problems there too so
you know it's it's interesting and
commendable to shift focus I think and I
think America is is a really really
interesting setting in general for a Far
Cry game I'm just I'm a little hesitant
about the direction especially with that
cover art which we talked about last
week here and I were both very like mmm
yeah they always they always have that
stuff with the cover art when four
released the cover art when they
released cover for four pagan min they
thought it was kind of weird depiction
of that and then a lot of people were
saying you know it's a white dude
holding his hand someone else but then a
lot of other people were like he's not
white he's not white yeah but I mean it
always seems like it seems like their
covers are meant to stir things up
almost and I feel like that's why it's
such a big deal when Far Cry releases a
cover and I think that's why maybe five
started with a cover release I I would
say so too I mean they kind of go for
the really eye-catching um to say the
least sort of cover mm um but you also
get like just to talk about some of the
other stuff that was released we get
these character vignettes for some of
these characters this is a trailer we're
looking at now but um vignettes are
great the vignettes are interesting and
they kind of give you a look into the
non cult issed members of that community
which i think is probably the most
realistic take when you're you're saying
like here's somebody whose father who
was was killed by the cult and she's
kind of taking justice into her own
hands I think all of that is interesting
that is a a good foundation for kind of
an interesting look into a very real
part of this country um so that
intrigued me more than I think the cover
art is on the extreme side I have my
biggest question about this game right
now is like will you be given a choice
to side with sort of one part you know
side of this argument or the
other in terms of like who should
dominate Rea like they they better not
give you the opportunity to sort of like
side with the bad guys here because I
think is manacle huh the fanatical
Christian cult this one right yeah I
mean this this game is setting itself up
- I think maybe illustrate some of the
problems exist in our country to degree
and to gamify in that way I think would
would totally turn me off like we have a
little bit of that right where the end 3
& 4 had these kind of uh tangential or
sorry like minor choices that didn't
really affect too much I mean like the
very ending of this have the game yeah
it was three was yet without spoiling it
was like yes I did this faction or this
tribe we're out yeah yeah yeah I could
see this has to be a critical narrative
if it's not a critical narrative it's
going to be it's just going to piss
people off mm-hmm and it's going to
create fighting among among communities
and stuff like in gaming yeah I the the
other thing that concerns me I wrote
about this in my article as well is um
you know when you consider the history
of a like violent force against groups
like this obviously less radical in the
group in this game um and when violence
is the core pillar of gameplay like how
do you how do you use a critical lens
that way and I'm interested because I
think it can be done so I'm obviously
not condemning the game outright I mean
we don't know much about it really
outside of what we've seen last week but
um yeah I think if you if you don't
critically examine the the things
they've set up then it's a total waste
like I think what's the point of it if
it's just kind of like good the things
are equally bad like I just making light
of the horrible [ __ ] that it's trying to
raise right like that don't do that
right so hopefully that doesn't happen
yeah I was one thing when I called duty
for release remember that's the first
kind of shooter I'd played that was you
know it wasn't directly about
Afghanistan and Iraq and the conflicts
overseas but very clear there's you know
talking about those things and that was
weird to be playing a shooter during the
conflict that it depicted was still
happening mm-hmm and it was the first
time I felt slightly uncomfortable well
right and I think being made
uncomfortable is is fantastic and I love
when media can do that and I look for
that and I think that's valuable and so
I am intrigued by this because I think
it has the potential to say something
very prescient about things that are
currently happen this is very very real
in contemporary modern someone talked
about Bioshock in the chat this is not
the same as Bioshock playing with
similar themes right this is like a
representation of actual place and date
and actual people went during the
behind-closed-doors demo that I went to
they specifically cited this 2016 event
it's very much a modern critique of the
US and it's something that I think can
be very valuable and also very dangerous
you're playing with fire yeah so remains
to be seen what they'll actually do with
the themes that they've clearly kind of
presented in the trailer in the
vignettes and just their own
presentations but I do want to get into
the gameplay side of things right we're
very familiar with the Far Cry
open-world formula at this point
assuming this will probably still follow
on threes and fours and primal and Blood
Dragons coattails
I do have talked about like our thoughts
on this kind of pastoral American
landscape Montana
you know like upper Midwestern kind of
area all right Rob you saw the trailer
and you're actually like dang and from
like a gameplay perspective this game
kind of has me hyped more than I thought
it would
yeah like Far Cry games are fun and I
very fun and I think for like for for
instance for me in that world exploring
with the wildlife and the sea could even
go for primal it's good looking but I
think it wears a little thin when you
start seeing the same stuff here I'm
hoping for like different types of towns
a very relatable or a very much
relatable environment you know like
street signs and like that my favorite
shot was the baseball field so that
should be fun to explore a mess around
and um there's a tower I guess it's also
the first Far Cry game with airplanes
daniyar you can like fly oh yeah Rob you
notice the airplanes right away that was
like that was so funny because we were
all in the office talking about the
cover
Rob's just like oh yeah those airplanes
of course of course he is is there
things whenever we do any kind of
trailer breakdown if we did one oh yeah
the call duty one I know my World War
two airplanes very well and I won't
speak about them whenever I see and so I
think there's the one that you see for
about I don't know four frames flies
over uh what assumes to be one of the
characters who is like you know your
your plane go to repairman whatever it
is you can imagine is he the one putting
the Gatling gun on the sea plane in the
trailer yeah
it's a it looked like a world war two
British defiant plane that had like a
ball it was like when the only planes I
have like a ball turret in the back
which kind of strengthens the idea of
that this game is going to be the full
campaigner is granted there's another
screenshot exactly releases that that
had a better shot of it um in you know
they'll take they'll take their own
approach on what the game I'm sorry the
plane will look like but I'm getting at
is you know the coop based of feature
that we know of is that you can play the
entire game with a buddy yeah because
you can have someone involved right
flying around yeah a past contacts three
had a separate co-op mode where you play
through these more just basic shooter
missions and then four introduced co-op
in just co-op and I believe you could
play through the whole game or known
another specific fortress assault
missions right and you could use it was
fun because you could have one person
flying that like gyro copter and then
your partner having a grenade launcher
in the other seat which that was really
fun but I was game this whole game can
be co-op where you could like lasso I
didn't it was pretty janky but you could
lasso the gyrocopter and I could just
like swing around and you'd fly me into
trees and stuff uh we also and this
wasn't in the trailer but in the behind
closed doors thank you there was a
pitchfork
um assassination that was interesting
was just like you just can throw a
pitchfork at somebody rip and then uh
dogs this game has dogs yeah these are
apparently it's a huge thing I remember
for they kind of introduced that with a
tiger when you had the shangri-la dream
drug-induced sequences but now
apparently dogs are yeah a huge deal I
like dogs
feel like this was a super hard right
for me being like this game could be
dangerous but I like that a lot
well they so can do you know much about
it that system is it like something
where you have dog companion the whole
time it's I doesn't look like a like an
entire I think you can kind of like not
summon them but I'm come to me boots
yeah I do
do my dog I'm not exactly sure we just
saw the dogs we were like wait there's
dogs and they were like there's dogs I'm
willing to bet it's very similar to
primal that had I think was and yeah
that's a way more recent in Blood Dragon
2 right like the one we could you based
good point and send your tiger but
primal is I'm always working to tame an
animal like a variety of animals yen
right haven't run with you so I think
that could be very much the same systems
right I'm aware that yeah so hey we just
take care of the dog make sure it lives
a long and happy life do we have to
throw it into the violence paint a cross
on its face like a cover oh no he just I
would just put like I would paint like a
middle finger on the side of the dog and
then send him into battle good reminds
me of like fallout 3 where they get
dogmeat right right and I'm just like he
could die if you brought him out in the
field you could die you never get back
and I remember it's like stay not coming
out with me this had known that that
aircraft carrier on the lockers forever
you'd have to White Fang him at the end
oh god just pretend I just want to
protect every dog yeah I want to use
those dogs ah but what else is new in
the so that's I really want to talk
about you know in a post breath of the
wild world not to Pete Brown this whole
thing and compare everything to Zelda
but in a post breath of the wild horizon
zero dawn year
well far cry 5 will be releasing in
February if every 28th of next year
that's enough so yeah uh I'm curious if
that formula will feel old by now
because primal the structure of it kind
of did right but then the whole animal
system they introduced something how is
more survival focused I liked and I like
that they stuck to its Stone Age setting
I think Far Cry primal maybe didn't get
enough attention because we were kind of
getting burned out on that formula I'm
curious if v has enough space bit like
since Far Cry primal or if they could
feel fresh very different
Zelda is a game where you're meant to
just sort of get lost in the act of
exploration
doesn't seem to be something they're
going for with this so I think you can
you can't really hold it to the same
standard necessarily maybe you could
look at horizon zero dawn but even then
the the modern-day placement of Far Cry
5 seems to just remove it so much from
that conversation right like I think
we're gonna be dominated by the things
we see and the tone of it all maybe more
than the actual gameplay and that could
make it feel fresh on its own yeah yeah
I would say like as far as Zelda goes um
the biggest thing for me it was like the
verticality of it in an open-world game
was like that's what I would like to see
more open world games I don't need every
open-world game to be like breath of the
wild um so I think there's still room
for it I agree with Peter where it's
like I think for me at least I think at
tackling certain narrative themes is
what's going to to set it apart I mean
they're certainly not pitching this as
an open-world game first and foremost by
teaching this as a game with the certain
subject matter right exactly that's what
they're leading with he's actually um
and so I know that like obviously
there's there's gameplay stuff like the
like weapons to have access to you and
being able to fly airplanes like all of
that is important but it's not the key
thing for me which is a little different
than you would expect for a far cry I
think a lot of people just have a lot of
fun with far cry um but again they chose
it not me so I wonder what airplanes
even have as far as value in this game
going back to airplane well it seems
like all the weapons and the vehicles a
lot of them are like you said it was a
World War 2 plane you saw in the sky is
this is just presumably like maybe a lot
of maybe veterans involved in this
conflict they did get a nice home with
them yeah agreement go to war go away
your last bombing run
I Sherman you're like [ __ ] going home
and you fly across the ocean you sure
they're using army surplus is way more
Sun yeah yeah I don't know like what are
you doing this plane you mean there's a
bunch of forests and trees I mean the
helicopter a gyrocopter whatever it is
you can you know you know volt VTOL
right you can land on come on guy come
into a forest like it is a traversal I
guess bombing runs do they say that
bombing runs there was shooting like
dirt with turrets strafing strafe sure
sure I don't know I saw there were
turret turret fire that's not how you
describe that but if that's not I mean
they made that that's a way how you
liberate a town right yeah I think you
you keep mentioning primal the more I
think about primal the more I see it
actually correlating along with the
companion system but like you know in
primal you could go hunting
bring back resources and trade with
people in the towns right like that
could be something as well mmm
because I think for didn't have much of
that I feel like you were sort had a lot
of hunting but is mainly for upgrading
your equipment just personally yeah like
that like converting that into like
inventory slots like I wonder if there's
um you know a stronger drive to trade in
for currency or something like that um
because there's a little bit of that
primal but yeah it's ultimately I think
were primal fell short was just kind of
a boring narrative yeah this is mainly
got context for what you were doing
right but right uh while we're on the
topic of primal I do want to talk about
our favorite Far Cry games because there
have been a bunch now and I think now
the franchise is big enough we could
talk about that so big it's so big so
that's so big and ground the old still
good
I went to my Richard Grieco - why did it
s all hit bro no just getting up do you
have do you guys have favorite fire
cries there's far cry there's far cry 2
there's three meters primal and Blood
Dragon predator instincts not super well
like I haven't played a ton of Far Cry
yeah but I'm just gonna say Blood Dragon
that's the right answer
yeah right answer let's I mean it's not
- is pretty great
- two is amazing
pretty no twos really good but that's
after that I kind of fell off until
blood dragon again ah love the 80s man
ladies man people with eighties
nostalgia I was never even alive during
the age either was I I just loved a yes
it was it was really good game was fun
there's more also like such a weird I'm
so surprised that this became a thing uh
it's looking to creation behind it yeah
but it's also just taking this was back
before a far cry for came out so this
was after three the racing has a
standalone 80s inspired retro kind of
yeah like it Robocop Judge Dredd infused
shooter it's a trendsetter a what a
trendsetter oh yes uh for what it
eighties throwback for all the things
yeah that phones just the first one in
Oh of the before that became a thing it
kind of fell in line with that that kung
fury like short that came out and I feel
like that one-two punch kind of inspired
a lot of people yeah um I the viewed
there's like this the story behind
actually how this got off the ground
super interesting I don't know maybe
google it but I forget where I read
about a story about just like the
Splinter team of Ubisoft that kind of
went off to make this and said what if
we did this and then feel like that
sounds insane you might as well just try
it
but yeah yeah and then obviously primal
and Far Cry primal got announced we
thought it was just another Blood Dragon
kind of spin-off a standalone title but
no it was an actual full game when it
released last year this point 2016 yeah
I think it was like almost exactly a
year ago um I think I think Far Cry 2 is
my favorite and it's tough because every
time I recommend it to someone I still
think it's pretty worth checking out if
you played state of decay the ally
system in that is very similar to what
happens in Far Cry 2 you've developed
these relationships with these specific
NPCs that eventually over the course of
the campaign will come in this African
landscape to save you when you're about
to die or come pick you up in a car or
help you with supplies or just come and
then when they die you're like oh my god
that was awful because I actually
developed a connection with them it also
reminds me of it's almost the up yeah
it's I'm like it's like the opposite of
shadow of mordor nemesis system sure
obviously not splashed out because
shadow Mordor was 2014 far cry 2 was
years and years before I think that it
was a cool predecessor to that kind of
state of decay shadow of Mordor emergent
narrative thing that you got out of it
and actually I cared about the NPC's
whereas three obviously they're mainly
quest givers you know therefore the
story for the plot Far Cry 2 takes about
like eight hours to really get into the
swing of things yeah because you have to
like start establishing the black market
upfront the first few missions it's a
hard game - especially even compared to
three where you know this tiger could
attack out of nowhere the the the grass
could just light on fire and come at you
but this was hard because you're very
ill equipped when you first get into
this landscape and you're trying to
establish yourself here but I know John
Luke really likes Far Cry 2 as well him
and Joey we put up a poll on GameSpot's
Twitter to see which one they should
play I think was last week and people
voted um far cry 3 I think I'm not
mistaken but 2 is really cool and it
came out as well because the original
Far Cry was just like a technically
impressive like shooter for the most
part right it wasn't really a thing that
had become a household name or like
really stood out for anything beyond
that but then this was like hey guess
what we can tell an interesting story as
well and make the gameplay part of that
event that's why I was memorable for me
yeah also how they put a shooter into
this open world and I thought it would
just be you know like going to different
places I don't know whose game places I
loved that it was cool to see how they
implemented a shooter or implemented an
open-world structure into a shooter with
this kind of characterization I really
liked and it's worth going back to you
still I think yeah I think it's it
hasn't aged too poorly it is harder it
does take a while to get into but once
you do it's pretty good yeah it's um Far
Cry 3 was the one that released in 2012
and really maybe it wasn't the breakout
hit for the series was definitely the
one that kind of brought a lot more mass
appeal to it yeah um it was December
2012 I believe and that was when that
really you know that this open world
kind of deciding whether to sneak up to
this outpost or just go in guns blazing
and then you have these skill trees I
hate the
um you know - the flashbacks to the frat
parties and the European the euro trip
kind of clubbing scene yeah it was it
was it something yeah it was something
like that uh
this game was great it still is but this
was the one that kind of established the
slew of you know farcry 4 farcry primal
Blood Dragon and then would you know
from what we've seen it looks like five
is going to be kind of following the
same open-world structure of you know
it's cascading quest structure you know
you uh you reactivate this radio tower
which shows you the NPC's in this area
and the random challenges in quests you
could do those unlock more which you
know you come across a new hunting
ground which you can kill this animal to
upgrade this piece of equipment and then
you can buy this weapon and add it to
your loadout and it was very good at
leading you from one quest to the next
without doing too many fetch quests I
thought and the world self was really
fun to explore because there a lot of
these secrets hidden around I figured
what items are actually searching for in
this but there are a lot of things there
were collectibles and things I seemed
kind of arbitrary but yeah this whole
emergent gameplay kind of focus where
what was that
what was that all right you know well I
thought well no no I'm sorry was not I
was coming at the gameplay he shot a dog
on he shot a dog and then he like kept
shooting out what I thought was the dog
was an alligator those rude being keep
going oh the dogs have since switched
sides
since Far Cry 3 yeah of course you've
got a cute dog in the new one you don't
have a pit bull or a bull mastiff dude
you watch mouths pit bulls are cute as
hell I know I know I'm just I'm being
I'm defending pit bulls so I I know
that's I'm saying I don't sure the dogs
they're only ever Tigers also wolves
anyway look okay well mom not gonna get
like a terrier out there attacking a be
so dope a chihuahua comes running at you
Fifi good
my face kisses get my purse well if it's
anything like these again the system
from primal is you don't have to kill
any of you dogs you just talk to some
hot meat and then it's your companion
companion come on y'all hot meat dude go
for some guy yeah forgot primal
definitely seems like the one that might
be I'm leading to this wolf system in
five uh but yeah far cry this is via
here we go primal uh primal i think
maybe like I said maybe people were
burnt out on the structure by this time
I think when they first announced it it
wasn't clear that it was its own full
game I think I at least thought it was
just a Stone Age Blood Dragon spin-off I
really like this game and then they
really set update like six months later
there was a survival mode so you at
night more predators come out and that's
why that it's it's tough to recommend it
now with everything else that's come out
but it was awesome I mean it was like
you know like a lot of games like far
cry 4 released that DLC that made it
harder right was more of a survival mode
in this game you're managing resources
so much because you don't have this
machine gun that you could just take out
anything with you know it's a bow it's a
spear club that you're trying to upgrade
predators come out at night so fire is
important being the stone agent makes
sense thematically I guess but you're
upgrading all these primitive weapons
and if this the survival mode really up
sorry
gets rid of the HUD and it also makes
more predators makes night even more
dangerous and I don't think you can fast
travel either I could be mistaken but I
didn't like to fast travel in teams if I
could help it anyway um it's crazy how
much of a theme that was last year right
every feel like every game was adding
they're like version of it yeah because
I remember the the first open-world game
that I guess like the most relevant
thing I could think of the first one was
New Vegas Fallout New Vegas and obsidian
did and they had that hardcore mode I
think there's a separate name for it
that's escaping me right now real like
realism I can't remember and you
actually had to manage your irradiation
much more and your food and your sleep
to a much farther extent than the base
game required but yeah Far Cry primal
focuses so much on hunting in the animal
aspect
and of course you encountered these
different tribes with themes like one is
just this brute tribe of kind of more
Neanderthal characters another one just
like uses fire as a weapon rather than
just for making tools and whatnot and
for food but yeah I really liked primal
I reviewed it last two years ago no last
year and even eight out of ten I really
liked it I thought like I said I think
it was kinda overlooked maybe people
were burnt out in this structure at that
point but I don't know how much you guys
got to play it but Robbie I gotta be
some fun amount of fun I did I had a lot
of that this was kind of getting I'd
just I just kind of got burnt out
playing it specifically I was I don't
know I felt I feel like the landscape
needed to be more diverse I don't know
yeah like I just felt like I was seeing
the same stuff doing the same things and
you didn't robot dinosaurs ran yeah I
needed some damn robot more robots and
planes to Spitfires
they had like a coop handle a bird you
can make in this uh did they done oh if
now okay um yeah because believe in the
sorry apex putting one in the ugh I was
saying it was hardcore mode in New Vegas
but I can't remember if in the base game
you had to manage your cold that the
temperature get warmer clothes you did
that was the DLC okay yeah I like that
aspect that kind of stopped you from
because I think you needed to like get
that that crafting skill from a person
right yeah after what they called him
but you it was one of the blocks from
getting you in the different parts of
the map yeah I think more than any other
Far Cry game Far Cry primal the
environment felt just as much of an
enemy like just as much of enemy as you
know the rest of the enemies did um but
yeah Far Cry 2 is my favorite far cry
just to give a definitive answer your
blood dragon yeah
your blood dragon yeah it's like today
yeah do you have one favorite I keep
thinking about Far Cry the first one and
how I felt about that game I thought was
a very neat game yeah as far as like
like the you know like the technical
advancements of it and just like running
around that island and stuff like I
don't remember like that like definitely
like finding a places like this or is
nostalgia goes like I remember that
pretty well I remember I played I think
it's Far Cry predator or Far Cry
instincts or Far Cry predator
and thinks I don't know it was the we
title when I when the way you was but
wasn't the first fire crab much more of
a shooter and less of a yes open-world
game yeah that like when two came out
that was a pretty big departure from the
first game yeah I I did not play much
the first far cry I think it wasn't it
also like inspired by another shooting
game you know all right and then that
happened and it was the plot threw me
off a lot I I'm curious what were saying
there wasn't there was like a couple of
shooting games right before the original
Far Cry and I feel like the the first
far cry was sort of like inspired by
those they were very much direct
shooters I can't remember the name like
inspired in what way in its setting or
its it's yeah it's aesthetic and it's
style of shooting like Far Cry made it a
more a more prominent game um God it's
not soldier of fortune
you're not talk about black are you no
no no okay way before black oh gosh I
haven't thought yeah it's strictly a PC
game that I just can't remember now
that's gonna bug me when did crisis
really I was what's a crisis no definite
crisis no and the original Far Cry was
2003 or four right yeah yeah sometime
early aughts guys kill me gotcha
alright well yeah man I have not seen
footage from the first part right a long
time oh there's Danny with the wire up
here oh yeah ah cool alright well I
guess that's our discussion of favorite
far cries and far f5 and it's also our
show like I said at the beginning of the
show with pretty crazy awesome giveaway
this week it's the razor blade 14 inch
gaming laptop which you said runs for
like a couple thousand dollars most time
yeah usually they're yeah they're not
cheap that's for sure
yes so if you do not follow a GameSpot
on Twitter go follow us and retweet the
giveaway tweet that Shiva who runs our
Twitter account just put up earlier and
as opposed to later in the week like we
usually do will select a winner randomly
next week I think we'll be announcing it
on the lobby next week but if not it'll
be around Wednesday ash when you find
out if you are the winner so go do that
because that's pretty awesome prize and
you have to follow us indefinitely
because we'll be watching your account
and follow us we're taking that laptop I
personally will come to your house and
sneak in and take a lap you'll need that
one but
what happens to zero uh did I Sunday
came over to my house in the ring but
you you guys work on this week Robin you
work on we're used playing titanfall -
and saying screw work ah no that's not
true but I am gonna play just a little
more because I'm doing some gameplay
I'll be up there like 7:00 tonight or
something yeah definitely 7:00 and then
yeah it's lobbies just pre e3 man
golly what about you same reviewing arms
nice um I've context that's just such a
weird thing to say I'm going around the
office and just judging everyone
somewhere what would you give
Rob's arms out of ten I haven't really
done a full examination do it right now
quick I'm just I'm just telling everyone
to work out more don't get whoa no
nothing Joe she's got an office like
this then raising the roof how you do
yes I'm doing a poll why with those a
bit full uh sweep so everybody get ready
for that third piece you got Tekken 7
Friday 13th yep some other game with a
big odd number
oh you I get it yeah I thought your way
is there a third one you're reviewing
that has an odd number in it no oh okay
I thought you're just no I'm joining you
cool all right and like I said we'll be
doing a lot of e3 coverage leading up to
next week uh III begins like a week from
this weekend
such a weird way to put it June what's
the first for us for us next week later
next week but yeah we started right
first conference is Bethesda the
Saturday before of young starvin xi e EA
EA is the first kind thank you very much
to the game and then you know like we'll
have Bethesda Ubisoft Microsoft Sony
Nintendo we will be covering all of them
will do be doing pre shows for them like
I said next week in the lobby that are
UK and Australia crews will be in the
San Francisco office so we'll try to get
as many of them on as possible if not
all of them and we will have a lot of
other stuff I do have one more thing I
want you to go watch as of today we
started a three-part behind-the-scenes
series on arcane
studios everything from dishonor to
dishonor to to prey to their early stuff
back in like 2000 when they first
founded when there's team of four people
if you're fans of those games or if you
just have an interest in video game
history in general we also track down
richard garriott and war inspector
interviewed them to go back to the
origins of arcane studio the pun
intended because they work to origin
systems and Looking Glass Studios back
in the day it's actually really cool
I guess history lesson and where games
are today or a lot of games are going
today in terms of immersive Sims in
emergent gameplay if you really like
breadth of the wild if you like Metal
Gear Solid 5 kind of in that vein of
emergent gameplay to get broader we talk
about how that style of game or maybe
something that kind of influenced those
games started so go check that out it's
called a failure defame how dishonored
saved Arkane Studios second episode will
be up tomorrow there it'll be up Friday
really proud of all the work that's gone
into those throughout the editing in the
shooting process we went down to Austin
and got to interview some really
intelligent creative interesting people
so go check that out on our YouTube
channel GameSpot yeah if I could add
anything to that is that they really are
great pieces or at least so far the
first one I saw you guys were able to
put a lot of time into it I think that
has really paid off so I really do
recommend it they're very well made cool
yeah go check that out and as always
thanks to Eric taejeong luke psyche and
richard lee in the back for producing
this show thank you everyone for joining
in the YouTube chat twitch chat on
GameSpot we will be back as always next
week we will have the entire GameSpot
international crew here in San Francisco
we're really excited to talk about what
we're excited for personally for e3 so
we will see you then